you look amazing hi you look amazing i
love your hair
all right well let's talk about our hair
because both of us decided to go for it
right in in the covid quarantine
um i have decided to just let it go i'm
having all kinds of issues with my hair
i think it looks good i like it you're
giving me like a surfer um situation
yeah i'm the a really pale surfer who's
never been to the beach
that's never been in the sun a day in
your life yeah and look at that it's
just like
it's getting real crazy but it gets in
my eyes how about you what are you
experiencing now that you've gone for it
well my hair doesn't get in my eyes
because my hair grows in this direction
um but i mean i feel like every time i'm
on your show my hair is longer and
longer
yeah that's no i was baldwin yeah yeah i
mean
it's beautiful what you got going on any
concerns though because
i have found that this is more
maintenance in some ways
at all i normally just i mean it is
maintenance if i don't do anything it
like locks up
the other day a spider fell from my hair
and landed on my face
and that's my biggest fear is
in my hair so your fear is that insects
will live inside your hair
100 like when i'm outside and there's a
bee i'm like it's gonna fly into my hair
get lost get stuck or like uh i'm afraid
that like
bugs are gonna lay eggs yeah i might be
it's okay we all have our own concerns i
saw
two days ago a labrador retriever puppy
fell out of my hair i mean there's all
kinds of stuff
i've got my i've got my taxes in here uh
from 1988 to 1997.
i'm filing stuff in here it's gotten out
of control